The Terminator has spawned multiple sequels
and prequels both in movie theaters and on
television, but as good as it is, it's far
from a perfect film.
To learn how, among other things, a perfectly
logical thinking machine acts like a moron,
keep watching for the dumb things everyone
ignored in The Terminator.
Since he's governed by a ruthlessly calculating
artificial intelligence, you might assume
that the Terminator would make purely logical
choices.
Watch the movie, though, and one of the first
things you'll notice is that his actions absolutely
do not reflect that.
For one thing, he can't even decide how quiet
he needs to keep his time-travel murder mission.
As soon as he arrives in the '80s, for example,
the Terminator makes an immediate effort to
get era-appropriate clothing that will allow
him to blend in to 1984 or at least blend
in as much as an insanely jacked Austrian
bodybuilder can, anyway.
"I think this guy’s a couple cans short
of a six-pack."
"Your clothes.
give them to me, now."
And yet, throughout the movie, he draws plenty
of attention to himself and never seems to
care.
He steals a pile of guns from a gun shop and
murders the owner with a shotgun.
This is the loudest possible way he could
do it, which will almost certainly draw the
attention of the police.
Even in what we see in the movie up to that
point, it's obvious that he could totally
kill the owner with his bare hands, flip the
"closed" sign over, and lock the door behind
him, giving him at a few least hours before
anyone thinks to call the authorities.
Shortly afterward, he kills the first Sarah
Connor he finds in the phone book.
He bothers to knock on the door and ask her
name, then smashes the door open and shoots
her six times in a quiet residential neighborhood.
As with the gun shop, he could've done it
all much more quietly.
And if he's not going to be quiet, why bother
knocking on the door and asking her name?
Manners?
Every now and then, you come across a character
in a movie who is so annoying and stupid that
you can't help but despise them as a viewer,
while the comparatively intelligent protagonist
doesn't seem to thoroughly hate them as much
as they should.
Such is the case of Nancy, the waitress who
ranks among the most frustrating characters
in the history of film.
Sarah Connor is working at a diner when we
meet her, and not only is her section is filled
with increasingly irate customers, a young
boy takes the opportunity to drop a lump of
ice cream in her apron.
That's when Nancy comes up behind her and
says that nobody's going to care in a hundred
years, which is the kind of contrived zinger
that she would only say if she knew she was
in a movie where time traveling robots exterminated
human civilization in the next century.
Then, she just bails, without even bothering
to help her friend and co-worker clean up
the mess.
That might not seem that bad, but don't worry:
Nancy goes completely off the rails a few
minutes later.
After the Terminator kills another woman named
Sarah Connor and it makes the news, Nancy
grabs Sarah and pulls her into the break room
to watch the report, giving her the most insane
reason ever spoken.
"You are not gonna believe this you’re gonna
love this!"
Why would anyone love hearing about how someone
with their name was violently murdered?
What is wrong with you, Nancy?
She's just lucky she didn't say this stuff
to super buff T2 Sarah Connor, who would've
absolutely punched her lights out.
From what Kyle Reese says, he didn't have
a lot of time to prepare for his trip into
the past.
After he's arrested, Reese tells the police
psychologist that John Connor's forces found
a time machine in a lab complex they captured.
Reese was sent to the 20th century, and the
lab complex was destroyed.
Even if they were hustling to get to the past,
though which seems like a weird concern when
you have a time machine shouldn't John Connor
have taken a couple of minutes to remind Reese
that it was probably going to be tough to
protect his mom if she thought he was completely
insane?
The first conversation the two characters
have after Reese storms into a nightclub blasting
at a gun-toting assailant, which to put it
mildly is a pretty stressful situation, involves
Reese overloading Sarah with a flood of ridiculously
precise information about the Terminator.
It's like he's reading the instruction manual,
going on about its microprocessor-controlled
hyperalloy combat chassis.
That's not information that Sarah would care
about or even understand in the best of times,
let alone when it's being shouted at her by
a sweaty man with a shotgun.
Her initial reaction?
Once Reese pulls into a parking garage, Sarah
understandably tries to escape, biting Reese's
hand hard enough to draw blood.
Can you blame her?
Reese is from a bleak, apocalyptic future
filled with killer robots, so the world of
1984 is probably as weird to him as he is
to Sarah, but someone definitely should've
given him some tips on how to start up a conversation
with another human being.
And even if they didn't, Reese is a smart
guy.
Starting off slow and then easing Sarah Connor
into the world of the "hyperalloy combat chassis"
would seem like a pretty obvious strategy.
As you may already know, the Terminator is
pretty difficult to destroy.
"It doesn't feel pity.
Or remorse, or fear.
And it absolutely will not stop, ever!"
For the most part, the best Kyle Reese can
do is slow the Terminator down, but as the
film progresses, the cyborg shows more and
more signs of battle damage.
Eventually he's completely stripped of all
flesh, revealing his mechanical interior.
The first casualties of the Terminator's outward
human disguise are his eyebrows, which are
burned off in an explosion after he attacks
Sarah and Reese in the nightclub.
It makes sense that he'd lose them, too, since
they'd naturally be singed off with that kind
of fire.
What doesn't make sense is that the eyebrows
are all the Terminator loses in that fight.
That same exploding gas tank that engulfs
his entire body and completely erases his
eyebrows has done absolutely nothing to the
hair on his head, nor do his clothes seem
at all damaged by the flames.
You could maybe write off the clothes by assuming
that the punk the Terminator stole his outfit
from invested in a fireproof wardrobe for
some unexplained reason, but for the hair,
there's no excuse.
Even stranger, this scene happens right before
Reese has a conversation with Sarah where
he explicitly tells her that this model of
Terminator has fully organic skin and hair
covering up its metal skeleton.
If those eyebrows are going, Arnold's perfect
coif should be dust, too.
After showing up in 1984 and eventually finding
a pair of pants, Reese tries to explain the
future to Sarah as best as he can.
He covers the emergence of Skynet and the
resulting nuclear holocaust, the rise of the
Terminators, and their grim plans for humanity.
He explains it all, but the audience is left
with a mystery: how does Reese, or John Connor,
or anyone else in the future even know about
Skynet or how their world came under the literal
iron fist of the machines?
Obviously, the survivors would know that the
machines were in charge, but when you think
about it, it isn't quite so obvious to figure
out how the human resistance ever learned
about the creation of Skynet.
From what Reese tells us, Skynet decided the
fate of the human race "in a microsecond."
All of that presumably took place within the
A.I.'s processors.
With the human race left scattered and without
access to technology or the power to make
that technology work, how would anyone be
able to access the data necessary to determine
how the world went sideways?
They don't necessarily need to know in order
to fight back, but they certainly need a way
to discover it if they're going to go back
in time and explain it to Sarah Connor.
The big twist of The Terminator is, of course,
that it's all one big loop.
After traveling back in time at the request
of John Connor, Reese and Sarah get it on,
and in the process, they conceive that same
John Connor, humanity's savior, who wouldn't
exist if it wasn't for the mission that he
ordered.
That's destiny, baby!
Even if you can get your head around all the
time travel hijinx, though, the fact that
their brief affair even happens is just a
little weird, if not majorly weird.
While they're on the run from the Terminator,
Reese ends up confessing to Sarah that her
unborn son gave him a picture of her, which
he kept and obsessed over for years.
He tells her that he fell in love with her
because of that photo, without ever meeting
her or talking to her.
It's more than just a little creepy.
Sarah is obviously still reeling from being
hunted by a killer cyborg from the future,
not to mention being on the run from the authorities
and having her roommate murdered.
And yet, even with all that, learning that
this sweaty weirdo became obsessed with her
thanks to a photograph that she hasn't even
taken yet is the weirdest thing that's happened
to her.
Why doesn't she freak out even more?
Or, maybe she's into it?
We're not judging.
It just seems like most first dates that start
off with, "I'm from the future," are already
going to be in enough jeopardy without adding,
"And I used to just stare at your pictures
for hours on end."
When he's being interviewed by the condescending
police psychologist, Reese says that things
in the future are actually starting to look
up for the few remaining humans.
Under the leadership of John Connor, they
had won the battle against Skynet, and smashed
the machine's defense grid.
Sending the Terminator back in time was a
last ditch effort on the machines' part, made
out of desperation.
"Why this elaborate scheme with the terminator?"
"It had no choice.
Their defense grid was smashed.
We’d won."
That's good news for humanity, but from what
little we see of the future, it's kind of
hard to believe.
In both scenes we see of the future first
with Reese and his fellow soldiers being defeated
by a flying machine, and then with a Terminator
infiltrating an underground bunker and killing
almost everyone in sight the humans seem absolutely
hopeless.
Maybe that's just how things are on the front,
but all of those piles of skulls aren't exactly
cheery, especially since Reese has to throw
everything he can at the Terminator to barely
slow it down, and eventually dies in the process.
So how exactly does John Connor manage to
defeat this unstoppable, self-replicating
enemy?
The humans have barely any resources, and
we see them hunt rats for food.
The fact that they have any weaponry at all
seems like at least a minor miracle.
It's hard to understand how they could possibly
win, no matter how good John is at looking
through binoculars.
The Terminator ends with Sarah Connor in Mexico,
on her way to becoming the hardened badass
we find in 1991's Terminator 2: Judgment Day.
She's got a new dog with her, presumably to
detect any other Terminators who might travel
through time, and she's recording a sort of
journal on tape as she travels, musing on
the question of whether or not she will tell
her unborn son that Kyle Reese was his father.
Of all the things she could be telling someone,
anyone, about the future, is the identity
of John's father really her biggest concern?
A time-traveling paternity test might make
a pretty great episode for Maury Povich once
his show starts up in 1991, come on, Sarah.
Let's get our priorities straight here.
Of course, that's not to suggest Sarah should
be yelling from the highest mountain that
everyone's going to die soon thanks to killer
robots.
As we see in Terminator 2, that's exactly
the sort of thing that lands her in a mental
institution.
It's just that in terms of what she should
reveal about the future, she's rating "do
I tell my son about his dad?" over "do I tell
people they should start building robot-proof
shelters?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.